As you've seen in this lesson,
there are a lot of interesting facets
to accessibility worth considering
when you're building your app.
We saw in the second lesson that a well
laid out focus strategy is extremely
important, but without focus styling,
that effort goes completely to waste.
We also learned previously that semantic
markup is critical to assistive
technology users.
And with styling keyed off
of semantic properties,
we can ensure a consistent
experience for all of our users.
Ensuring all text meets a minimum color
contrast ratio is an easy way to improve
readability for everyone,
particularly those users with
any kind of vision impairment.
And responsive design benefits
all mobile device users
as well as users who
employ browsers' zoom.
So keeping all of that in mind means our
final product is going to reach more
users, and those users are just going to
have a better time using our app.